want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you two you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
how millionaires start their day
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with idea number
one start with intention with brendon
burchard most people
are literally beginning their day
checking their text their voice message
and their inbox which is all other
people's agendas and needs from you
so again you are starting your day in
other people's lives and needs
and think about that and how powerful
that is especially for people like me
and maybe you like i consider myself a
people pleaser
like i want to do good for other people
i love to lead and caretake of other
people i love to be that person who
supports other people and some people
they give their whole life to other
people
without ever having shaped their own
life
all they do is do what the husband says
do what the wife says do what the family
says do the parent says all they do is
do what that inbox says do what those
text requests are all day
what are they doing
they're reacting
to other people's needs drives ambitions
so your whole life you're marching under
somebody else's flag you're you're
following without even knowing you're
building in the capacity to be a
follower
and i'm just here to say i listen i'm
not saying you shouldn't ever check
email i'm not saying don't check your
text or voice message notice what i'm
saying don't do it first thing in the
morning
when you check into your inbox you are
checking out of your life
when you immediately react to other
people you are taking yourself out of
strategy and thinking about the day i
mean for one second think about this
again go back to that middle school kid
hey kid wake up in the morning and
immediately i'd love for you to start
using your mind to compare yourself to
other people to be distracted
and only think about doing what everyone
else tells you what to do
will that child ever grow up with
freedom autonomy joy the significance of
building a life that is theirs versus
reacting to everybody but again if
you're waking up and that's the first
thing you're doing that is an addiction
that's leading to a negative result and
for those of you like yeah yeah brenda's
just yapping at me
the world's largest study of high
performers show
if you check your email in the first 60
minutes of the day
you decrease your weekly productivity
by 30
take that one home
if you check your email within the first
60 minutes of waking you are decreasing
your productivity
by 30
in the week
people say brandon i would love to get
more productivity everyone says well i
don't have enough time no you're just
using your time really bad in the
morning
to create these frames where you're
comparison so you're getting discouraged
to create distraction so you're training
yourself to be distracted throughout the
day instead of focus throughout the day
you're checking into everybody else's
needs so you think about doing
everything for everybody else and not
thinking about your dreams your wants
your desires your ambitions your goals
your contributions and i'm here to tell
you you have to be very careful
getting 30
of your productivity back though that's
so hopeful that's so hopeful and of
course people go well brendan that
sounds like pseudoscience well here let
me share with you results why is it
you're able to get more done each week
is because instead of doing those things
you're going to begin your day
intentionally
instead of checking in the inbox before
you even open the inbox sit back and say
okay
what are the primary activities i need
to do today
to move the needle towards my dreams
what are the primary actions
activities projects tasks that i must do
today to move it forward for me for my
dreams for what i want to create in the
world
who do i need to reach out to to ask for
help or to delegate to or to ask this
for like instead of you using the inbox
as a tool
to consume and do what everyone else
does use it as a tool to communicate say
okay if i'm gonna open that inbox the
first thing i'm gonna do is reach out to
people hey i'm waiting on this i need
this from you could you send that to me
okay great like do that before you
respond anything if anything that we get
more productive
also please think about this please
think about this
what if as you thought about the major
things you have to do
that you just blocked some time during
the day to ensure those things happened
so for me as an example
i never do email
before the major creative things i need
to do during the day like i'm filming
this video right now i've done zero
email today none because like this is
the major thing that makes a
contribution this matters more than
email
you've got to reprioritize your life to
doing the things that matter if you're
in my book high performance habits
you've learned about this concept called
pqo
it stands for prolific quality output
the difference between the most
successful people in the world and
average performers
is that they focus most of their time
during the week on average it was 60 for
them on doing the things that mattered
the most
to create the outputs that advanced
their life so for example an output that
advanced my life is video an output that
advanced my life is online courses is
the business work right that advances
what i'm doing here and i have to the
one of the big boulders that move your
life forward versus focusing on picking
up all the scraps and the pebbles which
is where do all the scraps of the
pebbles live in your social media or
inbox
i'm here to tell you but also warn you
and lovingly cajole you
use your morning to think about your day
idea number two reflect with robin
sharma we live in a world where people
don't reflect anymore a lot of people
are busy being busy but what's the point
of being busy around the wrong things
so for 20 minutes from 5 20 to 5 40 you
reflect you pray or write in a journal
you meditate you can visualize you can
script out a blueprint for a great day
ahead which habit researchers call a
pre-commitment strategy which actually
increases your willpower and your
ability to get your most important
priorities done idea number three claim
the day with steve harvey the first
thing i do i sit on the edge of the bed
i thank god i'm alive i just like waking
up
and i'm i'm i never say
speak negative so
man i hope i hope it's a good day today
no
i say today is going to be a great day i
claim it
i lay claim to it that's the first thing
the second thing
uh
at least 20 minutes
sometimes it lasts an hour it depends
i have a journal
i have a daily devotional called jesus
calling
and i have a new living testament bible
i sit down i just ask god to show me
what i should learn today
and he flips i open the book to whatever
he wants me to read
and i read it i highlight it i take
notes about what i learn
i study it
and i try to put it into action
and that's every day
now a lot of people say steve i don't
have time to do that you do have time
if you don't have time you should make
time
because
gratitude
is the number one way to become
successful
because the more grateful you become
the more things god will give you to be
grateful for
that's a very important principle
so if you start your day with gratitude
it's like this like check this out if
you if somebody come to your house every
day
and ask you for a cup of sugar
and you give them a cup of sugar and
they take the sugar and they just walk
off
and then the next day they come and they
ask for another cup of sugar
and you're a nice person so you give
them another cup of sugar and they just
walk off
how many days can this person
come to your house and get this cup of
sugar and never say thank you
how many how many times you gonna let
that go down
seriously
sir survey said you know how many days
not many because you're human because at
one point you're gonna say hey wait hold
up man you didn't came by here six times
i didn't gave you this cup of sugar and
you ain't saying thank you one time
don't come by here no more
so now let's think for a second
if this god wakes you up every day
allows you to breathe see it's not your
alarm clock that wakes you up
[Music]
your alarm clock goes off
god shakes you
then you hear the alarm clock it's not
you that's waking up
it's god allowing you to wake up
so if you ever stop to just thank him
for everything he's done for you
whatever clothes you got whatever kind
of car if you just got taxi fed and you
thank him every day for a list of things
guess what he'll do tomorrow
he will add to that list of stuff that
you can thank him for
and if you keep thinking you'll find out
that in one week
you'll have a lot more stuff to be
grateful for gratitude is the number one
principle of success that's what the
average person doesn't understand you
can do that today
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there idea number four commit to
yourself with lisa nichols i think the
number one thing i did to give myself
permission to stand in my greatness was
i got in the mirror i got in the mirror
and i did an exercise that's three
sentences and i invite you to do that
today
when you get in the mirror
finish each sentence with seven
different endings the first and always
say your name first so i would say lisa
say your name first i'm proud that you
seven different things that you can
celebrate yourself for
and then the second sentence say your
name first i say lisa i forgive you for
seven different things that you can
forgive yourself for begin to cut the
shackles to blame shame guilt and regret
and anger from the past and then the
third sentence is lisa i commit to you
that make seven new commitments to
yourself i did that every day every day
right after i brush my teeth
i would rinse the toothpaste out and i
jump right into making this declaration
to myself i'm proud that you i forgive
you for and i commit to you that that
way i began to fill my own tank up so no
one else had to do it and as i'm serving
others i'm serving them from my overflow
not from a depleted tank that's key idea
number five read with brian tracy one
beneficial habit that you can practice
every morning is to get up and read 30
to 60 minutes in something uplifting and
inspirational each day
when you get up in the morning and
instead of reading the newspaper or
watching television you read something
positive and constructive and inspiring
you set your mental stage or tone for
the rest of the day
throughout the day from the first day
that you try this you will notice that
things go better for you you'll be
calmer you're more productive you're
more creative you're more alert
you'll actually be more resilient and
will respond more effectively when you
face the inevitable ups and downs of
your daily life
just like vigorous physical exercise in
the morning will prepare you to be more
resilient physically during the day
positive mental exercise in the form of
inspirational reading will prepare you
to be more mentally fit
during the day idea number six choose an
idea with bob proctor people are always
asking me in seminars bob how do you
schedule your day
and you know that's not an easy answer
for me because every day is different
with me i do a lot of different things
but there is one constant
it's how you start your day earl
nightingale taught me that a long long
time ago he said bob it's not how you
spend your days it's how you start your
day you start your day off right and
everything is going to work in your
favor and you put seven of them together
and you've got a very successful week
so i said pick a good idea well you know
i have a book here um how to sell
yourself to others by elmer wheeler
elmer wheeler was one of america's
greatest sales people so i use that and
i just opened it here
what we call manners that's an idea what
we call manners
if i ran manually all day long if i keep
that in mind i want to be mannerly with
everybody all day long
that's going to help me so i take an
idea like that every morning and i write
it down i put in a piece of paper carry
it my pocket and that's an idea i'm
going to work on all day long if
something goes a little wrong i work on
that idea i take that idea you do this
and you're going to win and idea number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus clips
is make your bed with tim ferriss i get
asked about morning routines a lot i've
interviewed hundreds and hundreds of top
performers in various fields about their
morning routines and
where should you start this is one of
the most common questions and i'd
recommend starting off very very simply
number one when you go to bed put your
phone on airplane mode because if you
wake up and your barrage with text
messages and notifications and so on
you'll be immediately short-circuited
you want to have a boot-up sequence of
your own and i do believe as i've been
told if you win the morning you win the
day so what are a few ingredients if
you're starting as a blank slate i would
recommend number one waking up making
your bed i know this sounds odd it was
first recommended to me by an indian
monk he convinced me of the merits
because you are accomplishing
one thing at the beginning of the day no
matter what happens with unforeseen
variables for the rest of the day you
will return to a maid bed at the end of
the day and as a bookmark beginning and
end it sets you up psychologically to be
more productive and also to feel better
even if things go sideways later
in addition to that if you work at home
in particular
it's common that external mess
creates internal mess
in terms of mental state
so making your bed does not mean four
seasons it just means in my case pulling
up the sheets and blanket and so on so
it looks like
i haven't had an elephant rolling around
in my bed that's really quite simple and
then arrange the pillows in a semi
pretty fashion subjectively and there
you have it
what i recommend for many people right
after that is just do
10 15 push-ups or some type of sun
salutations or something like that to
prime your nervous system
and that's effectively from tony robbins
are many ways to do this cold plunge and
so on called shower but to get your body
physiologically into a state
where you can then sit down and have a
more optimistic story for setting
strategies and so on for the day if
you're in a depressed state you're going
to see problems instead of solutions and
ultimately have a really tough time i
think starting your day
on the right note and in the right gear
in addition to that if you want to add
extra credit i would suggest that you
consider either journaling which i do
almost every morning with most typically
the five-minute journal which you can
look up with my name you'll find plenty
of details i don't have any business
stake in it or morning pages which are
recommended to me by an exceptionally
successful screenwriter
for
using
putting words on paper as spiritual
windshield wipers in effect trapping
your monkey mind on paper so you can get
on with your day
those are two different complimentary
approaches that you can explore and
experiment with
i get my ass out of bed i come
downstairs
that refrigerator right there i fill up
ice into a jar and i pour up 20 ounces
of icy cold water and if you drink
somewhere north of 64 ounces of water
every day
i promise you you will feel better your
skin will look better you will your body
runs better so then i'm starting to wake
up somewhere along there i say hi to
dexter the cat because he's usually up
walking around and then i sit my ass
down close the door and i meditate for
20 minutes i do transcendental
meditation aka tm i've practiced several
different types and tm is just the one
that stuck for me so i'm not actually
advocating that you do tm but
just find out which one that sticks and
what tm is is just saying a mantra i'm
not crazy about that word it sounds like
whoa but it's a very very simple
practice anyone can do it
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to know what billionaires do to
start their day check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there when i coach the superstars i
notice they all have a trade in common
they have massive levels of what i call
curiosity iq they understand that the
person who learns the most produces